give me a specific example of a
situation that you viewed as a puzzle
and then how you thought about solving
it
okay well i did that today
i had a piece of a puzzle that got you
know that i understand better
so um i
i'm i have an art table downstairs and
i'm taking art classes on zoom and i'm
really having a good time
life drawing on zoom landscape drawing
on zoom
um all kinds of i have some post cancer
wellness spring offers um different
programs for people who've
uh in them are in the middle of
treatment or who have survived
treatment or their caregivers they can
take courses through wellspring
and some of them are art therapy courses
so i take those
so all that stuff is is is really good
for me and i sit down stairs and
and do what i want but
now i can't remember your question you
have to ask it again oh oh where's the
puzzle
oh the puzzle okay so i was in a class
a life during class on sunday morning
and
my husband came down and said goodbye
and i
snapped at him i wasn't i wasn't
you know i wasn't um i wasn't kind
he'd interrupt he yesterday he
i was concentrating on something he
interrupted and i wasn't kind
in my response and so later we talked
about it and i thought you know
i think i understand because if i look
back over the last 20 years
of having children getting married
having children having them grow up
i left my art largely behind for
a number of years and i could never
understand why
so i meditated on it this morning
and i thought back to my mother and her
father
who both had troubled
childhoods and
were prob and then i thought about their
childhoods and i thought well there
would have been fear
there would have been lack of love and
uh my mother was physically she was you
know some people you walk in the room
and the room is cold
so they're giving off something that you
know is
cold it's not a warm feeling a welcoming
generous feeling
and my mom used to have that happen
and so i would be jumping through hoops
trying to
get attention from her and to get proper
love in my direction when i was a kid
and it really wouldn't change her it was
what i wanted
wasn't necessarily what she needed or
wanted or knew about
so it was just something i was doing on
my end and so i have a tendency
but i had a good time with her if she
would color with me
so doodle art i don't know if you know
doodle art but dude
they sometimes have great mythic uh
doodle arts that you can color and my
mom used to color them with me
and you know i used to garden with her
but it that was work and duty you know
and
she used to sew me doll clothes when i
was a kid but she was doing the sewing
and i was doing the watching
but when we colored we colored together
so that was a shared activity
and last night i was babysitting my
granddaughter she's three
and she was getting sleepy and we went
down to my art table and
got out a coloring book and
and she likes to use my art pencils and
so we were coloring
pocahontas and and her uh hummingbird
and raccoon that are in that story
and i was quite enjoying it and she
would color a bit and then she'd say
grandma color here and i'd color there
and then what color should that be
let's give her pink hair red hair blue
hair you know where it's just
purple legs we were having a great time
and so i thought about all that when i
was meditating and i thought
well when i'm doing art
it gives me a warmth which was some of
the
only warmth i had with my mom not that
it was that drastic but you know
um my mom loved me i know she did it's
just that
there were certain times where i could
feel it more than other times and art
was one place
i really felt it and that might be why
although i have a
an aptitude for art that's also where
there's love
and warmth and so i really like to do it
and i left it for 20 years and didn't do
it
i until the art therapy until yeah until
i
till i had this brush with death
and renovated my house and gave myself a
good space
to set myself up
and made it a priority and
so i made i made the act i changed the
action first
and then when
the underlying trouble that had been
stopping me
i guess maybe then it was safe enough
for it to come up
and it came up and i barked at my
husband
which showed me that i had spent 20
years not doing what i wanted to do
and blamed him for it
in that moment or you realize that oh
i've known that before but it never
really came up
so that it was very much in the moment
for both of us to be paying attention to
it
and to and i wasn't i wasn't
uh confident enough or organized enough
to answer his question in a way that
could
calm him and make him believe that i
am addressing it and that everything
will be okay you were suggesting that
well actually first if you don't mind i
don't know i would like to know the
nature
the nature of your bark because for me
when i'm working i have a tendency to do
something similar where i bark but it's
not
but sometimes it's more caustic than
other times like
most of the time it's it's babe i'm
working i'm working
but sometimes it's like i can say it
more harshly or i can say something else
i don't swear
right but i i understand that it can be
i understand it hurts her at times
yeah i just said i said you can go
okay and do you mind what did he
do before that and then what did you say
like where were you in the kitchen and
oh no i was like
he came downstairs to where my art
table is into the basement that's where
i have it and i have
i cut a nice big hole in the wall so
there's light coming in
the stairs from the upstairs are they're
not solid so the light
from outside comes in that way and i
have a back
basement door with a big window in it so
there's light there's natural light
right there in the basement i have
really good overhead lights so i can
really
light this art table that i have so
that's where my computer is and that's
where i do all my art projects and
whatever else i might be doing
so i was down there my computer was in
front of me
it was obvious that i was in a class
i was drawing and he came down and asked
he said he needs some groceries
and i thought that's not
important right now to me because i'm in
the class so i said i'm in a class
and uh he continued and i said
that that was you know that was enough
that he could go
and then i called him and i said you
know just send me a text
just right you can go as in you can go
get the groceries no you can just go
he's honest you can leave like the king
says
you know but you know how queen
elizabeth she hits that little bell and
then whoever's talking to her has to get
up and leave
yeah that kind of thing yeah so you know
there's a lot of
um that would be pride i think or
or um a sense of entitlement for sure
so those those that kind of
understanding
so if i get that if i get a a clue
that i'm acting in that way then i can
address it then i can
say okay where did that come from look
back in my
whatever comes up for me when i'm
meditating and think okay well maybe
maybe i need this and i haven't been
getting it
and instead of admitting that i was
[Music]
uh
blaming someone else for something i
didn't do
or i was also um
whatever else i was doing i was kind
trying to control my environment
of things i couldn't control and can't
control but i was trying to
to get if you know when people do that
it gives them some self-gratification
because they've
gone off and and tried to
make everything better for other people
but
have denied themselves something that
they need like that that's a
that's a recipe for disaster you know
that's what that is
and so i think in the past
in my way of thinking that i was
thinking before
wasn't well formulated it was a
an old plan that hadn't been updated and
so
it wasn't a plan that was going to work
for me now
or for my husband